Robert Ford is the last American to be
United States ambassador to Syria sir
from 2011 to 2014 he left Syria in 2012
one year into the bloody civil war
because of security concerns
he's now Kissinger fellow at Yale and a
senior fellow at the Middle East
Institute in Washington welcome painters
has to be here you have studied this you
have been there where are we in the
context of Syria today and in the
context of the United States and Russia
well first I think the strikes that we
did last week on that airbase we're very
good it's time to try to deter Assad
from using chemical weapons so I think
that's a good step but it's only a step
Assad will almost certainly try to use
chemical weapons again and so I think
it'll be hard to convince the Russians
to lean on Assad to stop using chemical
weapons if we try to change the regime I
don't think we can change the regime
Charlie Russia and Iran are in in such a
big way that it's no longer in American
capacity to change the regime what we
would like to see is a negotiation
between all the different sides to come
up with a new God with having some
leverage on the ground well and you know
negotiation works if you don't have some
leverage you resigned as ambassador to
Syria under the Obama administration
because you were frustrated right well
we were saying in the Obama
administration we wanted this
negotiation I was talking about but we
were doing nothing to actually get to a
negotiation with leverage you believe a
force or the use of force and some kind
of military pressure I didn't want us
direct force involvement I always wanted
us to help Syrian fighters on the ground
who themselves wanted to negotiate do
you think God I it was interesting we
were talking just right before we came
on the air and the Ambassador was saying
as he just said now you believe Assad
will continue to test us they would like
you will likely carry out another
chemical attack I just won't go ahead
and raise one point on that people say
unless you can threaten his survival
nothing else will change his behavior I
think unless you put really great
pressure on him so that he's actually
not win
but losing he will have no incentive to
negotiate which he was at one point in
2013 and again in 2015 he was on his
back heels militarily once Iran stepped
in and then the second time Russia
stepped in there's a third calculation
here which is defeating Isis defeating
Isis removing Bashar al Assad from power
are they mutually exclusive the Islamic
state draws recruits from the
frustrations of people in Syria
especially Sunnis in Syria who are angry
at Assad largely and therefore the idea
that we can just bomb Isis and then
leave Syria isn't going to work because
will kill extremists Isis will recruit
more will kill more they'll recruit more
ends up being what a New York Times
writer Dexter Filkins calls a forever
war
now with The New Yorker magazine here's
what's interesting to the Russians and
the Iranians have said they will meet
force if there is another attack mm-hmm
so what does that mean where are we
going is this a slippery slope into some
kind of limited war with Russia and Iran
and the Iranians do have the capability
to get back at us for example they could
get back at us with our troops that are
now in Iraq so that's going to be a
tricky diplomatic challenge charlie to
both maintain deterrence against Assad
using chemical weapons but also
deterring the Iranians from hitting back
at us in a place like Iraq where our
soldiers are very close to Iranian
soldiers and Iranian militias because we
have nearly for about a thousand US
troops on the ground in Syria uh-huh and
5,000 in Iraq what would you do if
negotiations fail as they have well I
think the most important thing right now
is to re-establish deterrence against
chemical weapons that's a distinct
limited goal it's not a big goal like
fixing the civil war just tutoring the
use of chemical weapons because that
applies not just to Syria but that also
applies to Asia applies but does that
include chlorine gas yes absolutely they
have used chlorine gas after the time I
know that
and we could not get the Obama
administration to react to that even
after the 2013 deal with the Russians
Assad began using chlorine gas that's
why I said they test they test and they
test that's really interesting because
President Obama made the case look I
didn't act after the last big chemical
attack in 2013 because instead I got
something better which is I got Russia
to help remove a lot of these chemical
weapons out of Syria but it's clear they
still remain the deal was flawed that
way in that we could not get the
Russians to enforce it
there was an agreement in 2013 that a
faucet even used chlorine gas that the
Russians and the Americans would take
measures the Russians didn't keep their
end of the bargain this has been a very
smart discussion ambassador Robert Ford
thank you so much for being here my
pleasure appreciate it